SHANNON.
>> Shannon: WE WON'T EXPECT
THAT WHITE HOUSE VISIT ANYTIME
TOO SOON.
JOHN ROBERTS AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS IS ANOTHER FOX NEWS ALERT.
WE EXPECT WE WILL FIND OUT ONE
WEEK FROM TODAY WITH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS
DETERMINED ABOUT THE FBI
INVESTIGATION INTO
HILLARY CLINTON'S EMAIL SCANDAL.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE WITH US.
SHE HAS BREAKING DETAILS.
>> THIS IS THE FIRMEST DATE FROM
INSPECTOR GENERAL MICHAEL E.
HOROWITZ WITH HIS REPORT
EXAMINING THE FBI AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ACTIONS LEADING UP TO
THE 2016 ELECTION.
THE ORIGINAL MANDATE FOCUSED ON
THE CLINTON EMAIL CASE WITH THE
TITLE OF A CONGRESSIONAL HEARING
SUGGESTS THAT SCOPE MAY BE
BROADER.
THIS COMES AS THE PUSH AND PULL
OVER ANOTHER SET OF SECRET
GOVERNMENT RECORDS INTENSIFIES.
AFTER MIDNIGHT, SENIOR JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL TOLD
REPORTERS THAT DOJ WOULD OFFER
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERSHIP KNOWN
AS THE GANG OF EIGHT, ANOTHER
BRIEFING AND ACCESS TO FBI
CONFIDENTIAL SOURCE RECORDS.
MONDAY OR TUESDAY NEXT WEEK.
REQUESTED BY HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN DEVIN NUNES
WORKING ALONGSIDE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN TREY GOWDY,
THE RECORDS ARE NOT SUBJECT TO A
CONGRESSIONAL SUBPOENA.
THEY ARE EXPECTED TO SHED MORE
LIGHT ON ALLEGATIONS AND FBI
CONFIDENTIAL SOURCE CONTACTED
TRUMP CAMPAIGN NEEDS IN THE
EARLY STAGES OF THE RUSSIA CASE.
MULTIPLE CONGRESSIONAL SOURCES
TOLD FOX THE DOCUMENTS WERE
PROMISED FOR THIS MORNING BUT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT BACKED
OUT.
HOUSE SPEAKER PAUL RYAN.
>> WHAT WE ARE ASKING FOR AND
WHAT WE REQUIRE AND WE EXPECT IS
THAT CORROBORATING DOCUMENTS TO
BACK UP THE ORAL BRIEFING.
LAST NIGHT, THEY COULD HAVE
BROUGHT IT TO US TODAY AND THEY
CHOSE TO DO IT NEXT WEEK.
THAT DOESN'T HELP.
>> JUSTICE WORKMAN OFFICIAL ALSO
KNOWLEDGE OF THE RECORDS WERE
NOT AVAILABLE TO LAWMAKERS AT
THE LAST SESSION TWO WEEKS AGO.
ADDING "THE DEPARTMENT AND FBI
ARE PREPARED TO BRIEF MEMBERS ON
CERTAIN QUESTIONS SPECIFICALLY
RAISED BY THE SPEAKER AND OTHER
MEMBERS.
THE DEPARTMENT WILL ALSO PROVIDE
THE DOCUMENTS THAT WERE
AVAILABLE FOR REVIEW BUT NOT
INSPECTED BY THE MEMBERS ALONG
WITH SOME ADDITIONAL MATERIAL."
AT THE WEEKLY NEWS CONFERENCE,
SPEAKER SAID HE SUPPORTS THE
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATORS AND
EXPRESSED FRUSTRATION.
>> IT DIDN'T TAKE A SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE TO GET INVOLVED.
TO GET THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
OR ANY DEPARTMENT IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO COMPLY WITH
CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT REQUEST.
SPIGOT DEMOCRATS DISMISSED THE
SPY ALLEGATIONS AND DEFENDED
ROBERT MUELLER.
>> THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF A
SPY.
CONCLUSION?
LET'S WAIT TO FIND OUT WHAT
MUELLER FINDS OUT.
EVERYONE SHOULD LEAVE HIM ALONE,
LET HIM GET TO THE BOTTOM.
>> HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
RANKING DEMOCRATS HAD THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OFFER WAS
FRAUGHT WITH RISK, CITING THE
ONGOING RUSSIA CASE.
"THE FURTHER DISCLOSURE OF
INVESTIGATIVE MATERIALS IS
EXPLICABLE.
THE DOJ IS NOT REINFORCING A
PRESIDENT IT WILL HAVE TO LIVE
WITH WHETHER THE CONGRESS IS IN
THE REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRATIC
HANDS."
FORMER JUSTICE FROM AN OFFICIAL
SAID THE TROUBLE COMES OUT A
POWERFUL COMPETING INTERESTS,
ROBUST CORRECTIONAL OVERSIGHT